are you gonna move back to LA or now
ever I doubt I mean unless something
happened that I had to move back here
but I don't see myself back here you
don't like it I do like La yeah like I
love the weather yeah you know does he
live in L.A no he's in Atlanta
Georgia no there's another one dude
Atlantis I've been to Atlanta Atlanta
New Hampshire oh my God that's like one
time it's funny you say that one time
yeah he asked me he goes what time you
land I go three he goes a clock
[Laughter]
me and Andrew were just there I got
fined 10 grand
what do you mean what oh yeah yeah you
know I find 10 grand after the show
you're fined what happened ten thousand
dollars for why because in a theater
you're not allowed to show the audience
the inside of your butthole
you did that
you didn't used to do that Bobby I know
I know you're taking the whole Mitzi
don't support mediocrity a little bit
too far a mediocre dispatch
because it was a surgeon in the audience
okay
listen listen to me just listen to what
I'm saying Gary Jesus [__] Christ man
all right how smart is this there's a
surgeon in the audience and what do we
play a theater a couple thousand people
right he's in the middle there right and
I go well you know
game of checkup
check me out so I spread out my butt is
there any bombs this and that and he
goes no good on stage
and then I get off stage and then they
were like yeah you can't do that 10
grand and then I got on my hands and
these I begged please I'll never show my
butthole again and then they then they
go they let it pass so I didn't have to
pay it oh so that's good yeah yeah but
me and don't do that
dude we'll do that again yeah why don't
be showing your [__] on stage
[Music]
honestly dude no no you don't do it I'm
not gonna he doesn't do it I don't think
you don't do it I'm not because I'm
telling you Gary I do what I do
what I will I don't I don't say the n
word
okay
you've never said the n-word nope
on stage I've never either [__]
really [__] what did I say it you
had the joke Arnold
we had the job can I get the premise of
that joke oh no okay no no he used to be
like my okay all right over here though
I won't because he used to saying I'd be
like cringing in the back yeah yeah but
did it get a laugh ever or not it Gotta
Laugh but I do remember one time okay I
brought I brought a couple black people
if you believe that remember that joke
what's the joke I can't remember you
Billy but no don't unearth the joke go
ahead tell him the joke was I don't know
his dad or something he goes you you you
he's acting like he's dead yeah like
that yeah you you you remind me of
Arnold Schwarzenegger all right
Schwarzenegger and he goes oh I don't
look like also he goes no no oh no short
from Different Strokes
oh as his dad that was my justification
oh it's my dad saying it and it really
there's there's no here's the thing
about that word yeah yeah white people
can't say it I don't know if there's a
rule that Asians can't I don't know that
law because you know Puerto Ricans say
it yeah yeah there's a lot of Mexicans
that say it yeah yeah I don't know where
you stand in this I know I can't because
as as a Korean Asian dude yeah I'll
speak for my people do it we can't
really yeah we can't we women [__]
wait wait wait wait
[Laughter]
wait say that again
you're you're women wait wait say that
again but slowly I want to be able to
absorb it go ahead you're women
[__] a lot of black guys